para el congresista Edward Málaga
autores el tercer pedido de vacancia
presidencial contra el presidente Pedro
Castillo existe un irresponsable
desmantelamiento del Estado peruano con
personas que no son idóneas para ejercer
los cargos y están ejerciendo función
pública en las instituciones del estado
que han comenzado a tomar estos puestos
y además esto se configura en una
situación que se señala en esta pedido
de vacancia presidencial de que
configura la permanente e incapacidad
moral del presidente Pedro Castillo
porque se afirma que existen graves
vínculos con actos de corrupción para
que esa denuncia O mejor dicho para que
esta moción de vacancia presidencial
surja efecto se requieren 87 votos hasta
el momento solamente se han juntado 67
votos de los congresistas es por eso que
el presidente del parlamento José
Williams ha citado a junta de portavoces
esta noche para tratar de conseguir los
votos que hacen falta bueno Y mientras
en Perú rechaza fuertemente la gestión
del mandatario a nivel internacional le
brindan respaldo y los integrantes de la
alianza del Pacífico confirmaron que la
próxima Cumbre se va a realizar en Lima
después de que el congreso le negara el
permiso Castillo para salir del país
Sí justamente el presidente chileno el
Gabriel ha firmado hoy al recibir al
presidente Pedro Castillo en la
realización de un gabinete de binacional
entre ambas naciones que la próxima
Cumbre del Pacífico se va a realizar en
Lima la fecha se va a dar a conocer
prontamente después de realizar algunas
coordinaciones con los demás mandatarios
la sensación que hay es que entre
algunos mandatarios de la región según
algunos analistas tienden la
predisposición a apoyar al mandatario
peruano porque sienten que se están
cometiendo una injusticia contra él
Mientras tanto en el frente interno
según una última encuesta hay un
desesperación de la población por esta
situación inestable de crisis política y
más del 71% de los peruanos según una
encuesta piden que Pedro Castillo sea
retirado por su mala gestión